Oh
well there's something that interests me
and it does look quite promising and
maybe I'm inflating its importance
because I can understand it but for most
of the history of biology the stuff of
life well it used to be thought over
some sort of magic matter but then about
a hundred years ago the the cell became
seen as a sort of bag of complex
chemicals and so the chemical approach
to cancer is across well known in
chemotherapy about 60 years ago the
informational side of life became
apparent with the discovery of DNA and
the genetic code and so on and so now we
have genetics and bioinformatics and the
whole sort of information all approached
genomics proteomics and so on the
follows from that so we've got two views
of cancer cells bagra chemicals and an
information processing system but
there's a third viewer cancer cell is a
physical object it's got properties like
everything else it's got viscoelastic
properties got a mass it's got a size on
a shape and an internal organization and
it's full of pumps and levers and chains
and and other paraphernalia that
engineers and physicists are very
familiar with so it's a physical system
and what we were like to is integrate
all of these three points of view but
the physical part has been very much
neglected so for example healthy cells
and cancer cells respond very
dramatically two things I forces and
stresses in their immediate vicinity the
micro environment in which a cell grows
can dramatically affect its gene
expression how it behaves what it does
and also its physical properties it can
greatly change its elasticity for
example cancer cells become usually much
softer than healthy cells and they get
all bent out of shape and part of the
reason we can diagnose cancer is because
they become deformed swollen and unfunny
shapes and funny shaped nuclei and so
trying to understand the relationship
between the forces that act on these
cells and I'm talking about good old
push and pull Newtonian forces nothing
mysterious here
and their chemical and genetic response
trying to map those keralites I think is
a really important way forward so maybe
we can control cancer by controlling or
manipulating the microenvironment you've
got to get away from the idea of cancer
is a disease to be cured it's not a
disease really it's the cancer cells is
your own body your own your own selves
just misbehaving and going a bit wrong
and you don't have to cure cancer you
don't get rid of all those cells most
people have cancer cells swirling around
inside them all the time and mostly they
don't do any harm so what we want to do
is prevent the cancer from gaining
control we just want to keep it in check
for long enough that that people die of
something else to put it crudely and
maybe we can do that by controlling the
micro environment I should say that
tumors primary tumors very rarely kill
people of course if you have a tumor
pressing on a nerve or something it
could be problematic but mostly tumors
they can be shrunk and they can be kept
in check or they can be removed
surgically it's when the cancer spreads
around the body the metastatic process
that things get grim if we can either
prevent their metastatic process or eat
or prevent the cells that are
circulating around the body making a
home in organs where they don't belong
by controlling the the physical
properties of the tissues that surround
them in some way to be worked out then
maybe this is a whole new approach so
it's not you don't zap the cancer with
chemicals you don't bombard them with
raised to make them die and you don't
we're not talking about gene therapy
where you try and insert some sort of
gene to switch them off or something
we're talking about something much
simpler about controlling the physics of
the cells and their immediate
environment in a way that will change
their behavior and their gene expression
so it's really a whole new way of
thinking about it and I'm really hopeful
look so we're going to learn a lot of
interesting things I might say that this
cancer research I think it's really
important to inform cancer not just from
subjects like physics and chemistry but
also from astrobiology astrobiologists
have spent a long
and think about the nature of life and
its its evolutionary history how it
began how it evolved over time I think
they have a lot to contribute to the
understanding of cancer so I only I was
talking about the holy grail of
astrobiologists is to find life 2.0 that
is a second form of life right here on
earth i think cancer is life 1.1 it's
like another form of life it's closely
related to healthy life a healthy body
is one form of life cancer is in a way
nature's experiment with with life it's
its life almost as we know it but
modified in a certain way and I think
studying cancer it's not not a one-way
street studying cancer could provide
huge insights for astrobiologists into
the nature of life itself cancer
biologists really are not mostly not
very interested in evolution they
they're not evolutionary biologists
their cancer biologists so that their
cell biologist but we really understand
the nature of life itself by looking at
that long evolutionary history cancer is
not something confined to human beings
it's found in all multicellular
organisms where the adult cells
proliferate so it's widespread in the
biosphere so it's a phenomenon that is
deeply related to the history of life
itself so by studying cancer I think we
can illuminate this your life itself and
vice versa so my thinking and running
this cancer forum is to just get
expertise from as many fields as we can
bring it to bear on hopefully some very
well-defined problems in cancer biology
and really try and nail them and try and
move the subject along